i've been a football player my whole
life i feel like i mean i was
like i said you know going into the
season was to put myself in the best
position possible to
hopefully i didn't know how the nfl felt
about me you know before the season
because i hadn't played so
like i said coming in the season just
be me play my game and um you know
obviously when you win you know good
things happen and uh
a lot of good stuff happened this year
that's kyler murray speaking to the
media over the weekend and you know it's
been a few weeks since we sat with him
at the super bowl he i don't know maybe
i'm seeing what i want to see but he
looks a little thicker already he looks
a little bigger maybe he's been drinking
a lot of milkshakes eating a lot of
steaks peter but part of the goal is to
get him up to a more nfl-ready weight
and you've learned that he seems to be
moving in that direction
yeah i heard over the weekend uh that
he's up to 206 mike which is going to be
music to the ears of a lot of people
around the nfl
um the guy who he's most compared to
russell wilson has bulked up he was he
at the scouting combine
less than an inch taller than kyler
murray weighed 204 pounds and now
russell wilson is probably in the 218 to
220 range
um and he is solid as a rock if you go
up to russell wilson and say hey how you
doing clap them on the shoulder or
whatever you're gonna find a guy who's
solid rock uh kyler murray is high
worded in my column last week mike when
i wrote extensively about murray
you know he had the build as a football
player more of a mookie bets you know
more of a kind of a baseball outfielder
which
indeed a lot of people thought he was
going to be
but now
if he is up to 206 which i heard pretty
reliably over the weekend is what he is
it shows that not only you know is he
eating better he's obviously working out
and devoting himself uh over the last
couple of months since playing in that
last bowl game
he's devoting himself to doing what the
nfl wants which is to put on a suit of
armor
on a uh on a a more slight body than the
nfl would want at the quarterback
position
we had russell wilson and kyler murray
roughly two hours apart on set at the
super bowl and there was a noticeable
difference between the two i wish i
would have had them back to back so i
bet just in my own sitting you know five
feet away from them or less russell
wilson has that suit of armor kyler
murray doesn't and my concern was that
his frame may not be conducive to
putting on that suit of armor that it
may limit him that it may make his
movements tighter and more more
clumsy than otherwise they would be it
just didn't look like you could find a
spot to put 15 pounds he just looks
small not just short but small and uh
you know they'll find out on on
whatever day it is that they do the
weigh-in because it's down to your
boxers it's down to your briefs it's you
know stand there for everyone to gawk at
and get on a scale and they'll know
exactly how tall he is and they'll know
exactly how much he weighs when it's
time to go for that weigh-in peter
and you know the other thing i think
about all of this mike that we have to
keep uh that we have to understand
kyler murray is obviously it's good
right now that he weighs 206. he is not
an nfl finished product right now
under any circumstances and so i think
everybody who looks at him right now
is going to say essentially oh okay
what's he look like now what's it
because this is all you can go on but i
think
let's say he would go to a team and sit
for a year or so and i have i have sort
of said hey look new england's got
six picks between 32 and 101.
if kyler murray comes down in the draft
and is there in the teens and the
patriots like him they're certainly
going to have the ammunition to go get
him well to me
that's a pretty good spot for kyler
murray to go or to a team with a veteran
quarterback where he doesn't have to
play opening day
because then you say to him okay here's
the program
that we're going to put you on
and you're going to weigh 218 pounds a
year from now but now
we're still going to have a role for you
in our regular offense it's not going to
be a lamar jackson role necessarily but
we're going to be able to do some
different things in our offense that
we've never been able to do before so
who knows i think that you know as
lincoln riley the oklahoma coach told me
last week he said look
i think he'd be fine going into a
situation where he was tutored for a
while you know in in a different offense
because he was very good sitting behind
baker mayfield
for one year but the other thing is if
he has to play right away he's going to
be okay and so we'll see what happens
mike i'm i'm fairly bullish on his nfl
chances whether he sits for a year or
two or whether he has to play play
pretty quickly as baker mayfield did
oh i'm i'm fascinated by what he can do
and i hope he does great things how do
you convince a team that may be worried
that baseball is still lurking that the
a's plan to swoop in once they know what
the slot is and how much an nfl team can
pay and offer more than that to try to
get him to come back to baseball no
matter what he says that is still
looming out there and there's a chance
you put his name on a draft card and
you're ultimately not going to get him
to put his name on a contract
i mean a chance mike but i
i it's hard
to think
that
kyler murray with everything he has said
to this point
and what he's acting on right now it's
hard to think that
let's say he's drafted by the new
england patriots and let's say he has to
sit for two years
rather than be a starting quarterback in
the nfl
if that is enough to make him say
i'm going back to baseball
well he wasn't very convicted on
football in the first place i doubt
sincerely he'd say that plus he and his
agent eric burkhart they now know
that where he gets picked
means here's how much money you're going
to make you make your money on the
contracts beyond the first one
so i i don't really view that as that
much of a threat right now the only way
i would view it as a threat is if he
played football and stunk
and and you know then he might get
tempted after three years like if he was
jameis winston right now maybe he'd be
tempted to go and be i mean jameis
winston was the closer at florida state
i wonder if he's thought at all if he
has a bad year with bruce arians this
year
will he go back and try baseball we'll
see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports